carlo boso bonjour bonjour merci nous
recevoir ici dans al aïda ce qui est
votre école de théâtre on peut dire ça
qui existe depuis 2004 à versailles
tout à fait voila j'aimerais qu'on fasse
connaissance avec vous pour commencer
alors qui êtes vous monsieur vous êtes
né je crois en italie a mis l'audi a8
six vitesses que sa vie de couple et
belize d'accord après j'ai fait mes
études de l'été entre amis là d'accord
et au piccolo teatro de mylan et avec
giorgio strehler qui était votre
professeur il était mon metteur en scène
votre mettez en scène mon metteur en
scène et je suis rentré à faire partie
de la troupe des piccolos date de mylan
et on a commencé à jouer en france la
première fois en 1967
et voilà et où j'ai débuté ma carrière
en france et pendant que les messieurs
28 ah oui les un geste était déjà là gps
et dites moi vous avez aussi pas mal
travaux beaucoup travaillé je crois tout
différent carnaval de venise carnaval do
déjà elle mort en france j'ai participé
à l'organisation et canal d auchan en
france et en italie c'est lé canal de
venise et dans lesquels je me suis
occupé j'étais chargé des animations
théâtrales de les placer des valises
pendant le carnaval du 83 g 93 ok donc
c'est un peu à ce sujet vous connaissez
très bien plus mal parce que vous allez
vous en occuper ça fait déjà combien de
temps vous des parcs et jardins qui on
joue dans les parcs et jardins avec les
élèves de l'académie internationale des
arts du spectacle et c'est depuis 2010
depuis 2010 et on on a présenté des
spectacles de théâtre dans les parcs et
jardins de la ville
vous avez créé cette école ici nous
sommes à versailles l'aïd à ce qui
s'était pas versailles l'école elle a
été créée à montrer à montreuil sous
bois à dans les studios créée par
charles pathé en 1904 cette industrie du
cinéma qui avait passé les pattes et en
1904 et on est sur versailles à partir
de 2011 ça veut dire ça c est la
troisième année la troisième année qui
en assurera la ville de versailles s'est
transférée
et bien des 1000 euros ce vol est alors
cette école comment elle fonctionne
c'est combien d'années d'études s'est
ouvert à qui plus qu'une école s'il s'en
extrait c'est une scène très des
formations artistiques savez directement
à des cours pour les enfants pour les
ados et pour les adultes et on a aussi
des cours de professionnalisation ceara
présentent-ils centaines de personnes
qui sont ici chaque semaine pourrait
pour faire du théâtre g à différentes
différente au niveau c'est l'écologie
avait pas d'eau professionnel tout à
fait la partie professionnelle entre
guillemets que c'est avec et qui ont
participé au festival des molières et il
va présenter trois cours de théâtre et
environs ses 1500 terre des formations
professionnelles chaque année aaron
harang nuit tout à fait et combien tu as
à dieu ces formations et trois armes
il ya trois ans et puis une quatrième
année de professionnalisation ça veut
dire etc et et tous les élèves qui
sortent de l'académie dans la
possibilité de claire décret leur propre
compagnie est de présenter des
spectacles soit le festival d'avignon
mais soit en tournée en france et à
l'étranger et nous on les suivait dans
la professionnalisation
alors il doit exister des milliers de
compagnies qui voyez vous ça doit il
s'aimait pas ça c'est tout à fait ce
moment des liens des compagnies
professionnelles qui sont surpris si la
recette et compagnie qui tourne un petit
c'est en tout cas tout à fait que ça et
donc moi j'aimerais qu'on parle un peu
plus de la commedia dell'arte qu'on est
prêt expliqué un peu parce que tout le
monde connaît tout le monde sait ce que
c'est j'avoue que moi on cherche un peu
j'ai appris plein de choses parce que
c'est un genre vraiment à part et c'est
ce que vous allez nous montrer pendant
le mois molière
mais déjà ce qu'on pouvait nous dire un
peu en quoi ça consiste la commedia
dell'arte bélanger fort mérité un privé
il est né en italie justement tu avais
dix dessins et dans le cadre du canada
john c l'istituto nalisation de diorite
les carnavals et pour fêter ce que les
carnavals l'intérieur du carnaval on
construise un grand découper que ce
terroir carnaval comme on fait encore
aujourd'hui un ami parenté ville
aimerait y avait tous les peuples qui
faisait des procès au roi carnaval ça
veut dire qu'ici il y avait la crise
économique que c'était la faute à la
cavale ça y est tout le monde de se
décharger sur le roi carnaval et était
équipée des monstres et abattre secondes
et à la fin on l'est on le chantier on
les condamnés à mort t on les brûler sur
la place publique et et on faisait la
fête
ça c'est dit
c'était le mercredi des cendres et
c'était la carène d'accord mais la
presse il estime c'était 17 et ri de ça
veut dire et qui via des personnages
populaires qu'il faut mettre les procès
aurait carnaval c'est l'occasion nous
est donné la parole au peuple à se lier
à l'intelligente il n'avait pas le droit
de parler parce que la parade est amoral
et on a inversé les rôles séoul et la
commedia simplicité sur les jeunes et
les plus âgés
ça veut dire que c'est une forme de
théâtre intérim et politique car elle ça
permettait de dénoncer les vices et pour
faire triompher la vertu à la fin tous à
cet effet par des types peu ça veut dire
que les comédiens il avait une division
et d'équipés représentative et de les
différentes catégories sociales et les
catégories sociales qui existait les
docteurs qui rappelle que les
universités les capitaines et qui est
représentée l'armée
l armée qui représente à la fois au
début par dont un peu idiot pied après
au fil des siècles devenu un peu moins
bête est plutôt rusé et a fait un
atterrissage est tout à fait tard et
pantaloni si la démarche a été la
mondialisation du commerce
ça va présenter ses d'équipé pendant
tout le monde c'était comme un théâtre
très populaire mais dans le contexte est
populaire dans des places dans des lits
qu'ils n'étaient pas des billes au
théâtre
alors justement ça c'est intéressant
parce qu'en fait c'étaient les troupes
qui arrivait oui voilà qui s'enseigne
avaient ils avaient des scénarios ça
veut dire on improvisait s'était formé
théâtre improvisé ça veut dire que tous
les acteurs il est d'un projet leur
texte mais il y avait un scénario oui
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a écrit comme un
canevas commun canada et à ta main et
après on improvise et l'âme et le coeur
l'esprit c'était l'acteur qui les donner
à cette can a vaqué vos lecteurs et je
crois qu'il s'inspirait des vraies
histoires qui se passait dans les ide
dans les villages et les zones actives
comme utiliser des sujets ancien si vous
voulez vous on est tous les scénarios de
comédiens ils ont la main mise partout
dans tout ce serait d'ailleurs jours on
parle aux du pouvoir de l'amour pour le
faire triompher un jour de l'amour du
pouvoir
ça c'était un mélange et après quand on
arrivait d'un village on sent fort mais
qu'est ce que ça peut être les faits
divers et on essaie de les réintégrer
dans les scénarios mais pas un hacker
voilà parce que c'est pas le tout
d'arriver de jouer non les gens voient
les villages
voilà et puis surtout que le public
reste tout à fait les trois captives est
intéressé à lui écrire ce que là c'est
celle du théâtre de plaisir du théâtre
qui fait rire tout va en comparaison
avec le théâtre parfois un pur sérieux
les destinées à faire rire les gens la
comédie de molière de faire ailleurs le
roi et le peuple pour le faire réfléchir
et apaiser les airs et son ressemble
après il fallait être fédérateur
sûrement très important et alors et
aussi le rôle des femmes parce que il ya
des femmes qui sont acquis ont leur rôle
et colombine et je sais plus qui et je
crois que c'est assez nouveau
c'était nouveau se disent inquiets
romaine mais dans la commune entre la
grande nouveauté c'était pas que c'était
des hommes mais qui jouait le rôle des
femmes mais pour dire aux femmes et qui
va le faire et à l'improviste il ya des
femmes qui pendaient des parents la
parole sur les plateaux alors c'était un
révolution sociale surtout dans le vième
siècle 17e et c'est que cette crise
était pas facile à vivre
vers la fin mais l'improviste dans des
théâtres prendre la parole en public et
prend de l'importance extraordinaire
révolution ne s'agirait que celle qui
parle de ce problème et c'est pas les
hommes et qui passent des prix n'est pas
d'interpréter très bien et donc voilà
vous allez justement tout le molière qui
approche la la fin du mois de mai qui va
durer jusqu'à fin du mois de juin vous
vous présentez quatre créations cadres
vont t'aider reprise éventuelle des
nouvelles créations
ça veut dire que dans les mas molière et
comme vous avez vu dans les programmes
on est on l'a présenté différentes et
spectacles dans différents ateliers
déjà la ville ça veut dire dans des
parcs et dans les abers j'adore les
places aussi voilà comme à l'époque
comme à l'époque
et là on fait 23 la présentation de
cette année pendant que les quatre
week-ends et les ont là on présentait
déjà des choses qu'on avait présenté les
années passées dans déplacer dans
lesquels on n'était pas l'année passée
si vous voulez et on présente aussi de
nouvelles créations n'a bien entendu pas
que de la comédienne a fait ça et dire
il ya toutes formes toutes les
formalités attrayant tout cas ils
forment des théâtres populaires cible ça
veut dire tout public ça veut dire que
ça veut dire tout public et tout public
et tout public et dans lesquelles il n'y
a pas de barrière ni culturelle ni
linguistique sa deuxième femme a été
être couvert d'un bélier qui sont pas
destinés au théâtre et qu'on cherche
c'est d'être récupéré pourquoi c'est
plus intéressant ça suffisait beaucoup
plus intéressante pour nous surtout des
mois molière et chanteur et batteur
mathieu canova sur la place du marché
on sait qu'il est public il est là oui
il est déjà là et en plus ils trouvent
lé théâtre dans l'espace et qu'il
connaît déjà et ça ça a sacré ça donne
une cote exceptionnelle aux dires et
dans le même temps que c'est une idée
qu'ils appartiennent déjà au public et
dans lesquels on est au tce
c'est beaucoup plus
la même chose qu'en donnait enfin ses
délégués cessera ordinaire à la
cathédrale est de voir des publics et à
la messe et qu'après il assiste à une
autre forme de mecelec que ceux des
théâtres mais c'est beau parce que ça
veut dire
il y à une rencontre entre les
différentes républiques et pris en
compte a prévu entre eux vis ans peuvent
y arriver d'un patrimoine et avoir une
très tôt des comédiens avec des
comédiens costumés ou au milieu du parc
vous en train de jouer ça ccpz ionel
c'est la meilleure façon de mettre le
pied et je dois dire que sur ça la
vision n'est qu'il a de la
fonctionnalité entre dans la société
l'émergent choix d'imagés insiste
ordinaire et c'est ce qu'il a voulu
faire ses achats liés à l'impression à
tous les bons de ses cadres mais damas
pour tous donc dans tous les quartiers
tous les jardins donc là on va écouter
ce que je propose c'est que les gens se
les personnes regardent ce programme qui
sera internet partout oui voilà ce sont
des créations qui après parts avignon
tout ça tout à fait donc qui ont une vie
après versailles oui
et est ce que ça serait pas envisageable
par exemple de faire une petite création
improvisée avec le problème de
versailles le fait divers ou c'est pas
possible ça mais j'en écris d'entrée
drogue des bus 10 ans la guerre est bien
entendu tous les années dans les
spectacles et dans les créations est
axée sur la comédienne puisqu'elle
présentait pas que des comédiens ont
présenté corner dans les
la présentation est axée sur la commune
vient on parle de les problèmes de la
vie c'est une évidence avions intégré
pour intégrer des années de la vie
conseille les bruits qui se reconnaît
aussi a vraiment tout à fait ok bon
écoutez j'ai hâte de voir merci carlo ya
plein encore plein de choses à dire mais
le temps était court ces données avant
de vous las sur les places dans les
chartraines dans la bulgare et vous
participez aussi au festival
aussi on a créé un festival à 1000 de
france qui se prétend déjà très content
et art qui existent dans toute
l'ile-de-france juste maintenant capital
imminente peut-être dans ce moment
tonnerre les jardins de bon matin
ok un gros merci merci à vous et à très
vite j'espère merci a bientot oui à
bientôt
merci